Fuli I'm good but now I'm good buddy the
[Music]
Caribbean is home to some of the world's
most recognizable curry from Kingston
Jamaica to Kings County Brooklyn curry
goat is a staple dish on dinner tables
and restaurant menus everywhere still
the dish doesn't always get as much
attention in the US as beef patties for
jerk chicken to understand this curry
shop heavy-hitter I'm meeting up with
two true Jamaican legends Grammy
award-winner rapper and singer Sean Paul
and his latest study rocks I need to
chiang ching
we're headed to Gladys a new school home
for jerk chicken to get a crash course
on all things Jamaican before eating
curry goat with two generations of
dancehall icons let's get it
jerk chicken and beef patties have
become a part of New York culture mm-hmm
but in Jamaica how big of a deal is
curried goat
core you know once you go curry oh my
god Gordon question between Indians and
West Indians is that curry go does it go
curry we don't know what you mean kind
of cool okay Kurt your back said that
right you are asking if it was important
that yes yes I was you know what you say
imagine the farm I would avoid don't
watch months no much I bought cars good
guys enough Aaron yeah one actually eat
good and make sure they're now ruin up
on them too much heels and tough up that
dead before time talk Morton you stick
around would ya oh that one more
okay so I need to learn some slang
before we continue I have a couple
actual terms that I wanted to throw out
at you and you tell me the meaning of
that
what about blasting flossing blessing me
near the bar scene you know you're
endorsing money at our scene oh yeah
right no more flossing yeah you're
glossing okay this next one I might say
it wrong
geez some peas like surprise
yeah sometimes they really come from
what toy is broken English okay
so G's on peas we didn't want to say
doors Jesus Christ
I'll take it in vain so it's a course
where it almost are a surprise word Joe
look touching cheese on bt geez thanks
surprise big surprise what about Duffy
no don't be
it's pretty good that's a spirit is so
oh also people talk about it like you
know in here in Brooklyn you know people
say they caught a body you know what
that means you mean you kill something
right so anyway say you make a dopey
yeah you made them into a ghost yeah
first up we have Gladys jerk chicken the
meat is first rubbed with a 50/50 blend
of sugar and salt then it's rubbed again
with house-made jerk spice a blend
including scallions white onions thyme
garlic allspice ginger and scotch
bonnets the dish is served with a
house-made jerk sauce all right we got
jerk chicken here are you guys ready to
take our first bite in the kitchen if
you make good church again you cook it
on the mentor sticks and you also use
the siphon I can taste a lot of pimento
in it and it looked like in the slow
cooker smoke is very important to the
church again there's no smoke it's a
joke on the outside and nice I'm charred
on the inside a knight ourselves yeah I
really hate when you get jerk chicken
and there's no implemental you don't
taste that the minute it's not Georgia
peanut what is the deal with the scotch
bonnet I love it scotch manatee is a
habanero pepper our soil in Jamaica is
very rich bananas taste sweet peppers
are very hot and spicy our coffee is
very tasty
yeah what scotch bonnet something that
we even cut it off and put it in this
paper with the vinegar in this sauce
caught up in here with vinegar with
onions and
you put that over your food I mean so
you don't just bite the Scotch body
another bell pepper is a popular all
right well this spice level I can handle
it I'm a little nervous what's next but
I think I got this with your support so
save some room cuz we got another dish
coming up next up we're gonna be tasting
some Jamaican beef patties seasoned
ground beef and other fillings are
folded into a turnover and baked inside
a flaky yellow crust we're gonna be
eating two patties today one from a
mom-and-pop patty shop down the road and
one from a mass-market chain to see
which one comes out on top you don't
have anything from Casey's buddies in
Jamaica everybody's the same size okay
these are different shapes on different
sizes yeah and the crooks don't look
slightly he as as usual but I'm in
fartin which means I'm in New York yeah
I'm gonna work with it I won't taste the
Patti so the first one yummy this big
one here
[Music]
so we all tried the mom-and-pop one what
are your thoughts when the mom-and-pop
there's more beef than crust yeah
and we've need more spice I think the
outside do you need more Chris more
plate here you know acknowledged easing
the air pop I need to fall oh where is a
good party in Jamaica you're fooling ah
yeah yeah this is like a meat loaf I
would say yeah it's more like a meatloaf
meat fruit yeah so we're gonna try the
chain restaurants one right now and see
what our thoughts are a lot more spicy
and more authentic meat it's uneven
across with our crust and falling off
surprises
yeah but I must about 10 ml on that my
muscle dividend we destroyed it
have you ever had a weed beef patty well
I stopped smoking for five years I used
to make a oil
I thought of olive oil or coconut with
the infuse to get you high for about 15
hours so yeah sometimes I put it in the
Coco bread I'll put the party in there
and everything and you have a nice party
huh huh yeah yeah I put it on salad up
within sandwiches oh yeah good vibe huh
thank you for us so before we dive into
the curry goat in the oxalá
ticket to the kitchen to get more info
on these two staple dishes my name is
Rina Felix I'm one of the owners of
Gladys jokes Enza for five years Avenue
we're not really authentic Jamaican
restaurant be more like a fusion style
all types of dishes all over the
Caribbean but the Indian do did curry
must like different than in Jamaica more
spices to it compared to um Jamaican or
any curry from the Caribbean we do our
curry goat hair differently from other
sports we have our big steam kettle get
it going for a couple of minutes
get out all going first leave nice and
hot then we add our curry powder let's
sweat out for like 10 20 minutes get all
of using a lot flavor out then we add
our ginger garlic a Banaras cause boil
and then let it go in for another half
an hour then our tomato peel then we add
our hook of milk then
laughs is the good the Axio done
slightly similar to the goats
you know you added salt pepper tomato
peel and that's all you need to know and
flavor is right there
texture is very good in two depends on
how you cook it to be a little tough on
the outside to be nice and tender on the
other side I love to cook in Korean food
I'll put them on my passion my love into
it so I'll say it's more like soulful
you get a good cut I get like more like
a scrub and I make something out of it I
could get like a cheap ass goods and
turn into a very good meal I make some
money out of it so is the way you use
whatever whatever you go to your
advantage
[Music]
we got the curry go we got the oxtail
and the rice and peas yeah okay I know
Cory well I'm not really a fan I'm so
you wouldn't consider the oxtail yeah no
no no is that more bronze do what would
you say is the difference between Indian
curry go and Jamaican curry go Owen is a
lot more thicker sauce I think on
curries I'll make sure of like seven
different spices anyway tamerica the
oxygen actually sucked a tiny Manticore
ago right yeah we would it is not a
sucker a fatty would by the side is
amazing have you ever had the Indian
yeah I like always better I know you
know what I think I like yours better -
it's good I was never really into like
we call it [ __ ] it up welcome which was
like the word for goat curry yeah one
thing I've noticed is that North
American culture they're a little bit
afraid of eating things like go Hawks
tell where do you think that stigma
comes from America's gotten used to
everything being packaged so much meat
must look like a meat patty hamburger
patty
fish must have the head on it with the
eyes looking at you also these are
dishes that back in a day with
plantations and slavery the plantation
owner will be eaten a big roast beef but
he would throw away the oxtail and out
of that and people learn how to make it
taste amazing as you said it's upstate
balance his feel good food and
definitely Sunday food for me so Sean
Paul you've been a part of this game for
20 years I remember my sister buying
your CD in 2002 your music kind of
really honed this childhood sound
how is dancehall music changed within
those last 20 years when I love
dancehall music as a kid hearing great
artists like super cat and shamrocks
they're talking in the way I talk to my
friends they're talking about things
that we do I just loved it and here I
thought everybody in the world if
nothing is changed in that it's a bigger
game now you could make more
opportunities with a bigger game I see
things in a positive way you know I'm
doing this because and a lot of the
music and dance on which I had to make a
world or what downside is they get the
message put it stuff across the world
dismissal so the future bright set a
future bright well thank you for joining
me
I'm stopped thanks for teaching me about
college Jamaican slang let's have a good
cheers are you ready he's busy he's in
the arts Dale the Turning Tables
you
[Music]
yes my simple feet